Happy New Year everybody it's officially
2017 it's a whole new year for people to
complain about and be upset
I can't wait today we're going to do
something new that I hope becomes a
yearly tradition on my channel and
that's talked about the most underrated
and overlooked films of 2016 now what's
the difference between those two terms
to me for me overlooked is pretty
self-explanatory it's a film that I
thought was good that not a lot of
people saw underrated is a little bit
different for me this is a film that I
really appreciated and maybe even loved
but maybe critics and audience members
didn't feel the same way and I think it
deserves a little more notice
and obviously some titles are going to
carry over from my best of the year list
and we're going to get a little bit of
repeats here but that's to be expected
let's get going this is not in order
this is not a list this isn't in some
sort of descending or ascending order
this is just a bunch of films that I
think you should see at some point if
you haven't already starting out with
overlooked
the boy and the beast this film was on
my best of the year list I think it's a
fantastic anime film that not enough
people saw if you get a chance to see
this movie or even if you don't have a
chance just just try to find it and
check it out I think it's worth your
time in the category of underrated
another film for my best of the year
list Swiss army man this film was so
different and so subversive it had a
farting corpse a lot of people didn't
like it people walked out of it at film
festivals that was kind of dumb cuz this
was a really really original and
different movie and it should be praised
for that next in the category of
overlooked sing Street this is a film I
didn't get a chance to review but I did
see oh my gosh I love this movie this
director is very fond of making movies
about musicians and I think this is his
best one that he's made so far it's an
extremely enjoyable movie about a boy in
Dublin who wants to impress a girl so he
starts a band because how else do you
impress girls I found this movie awesome
I didn't get a chance to review it and
it was on my honorable mentions list for
the best of 2016 last time I checked it
is on Netflix if you're watching this
video in the future it might not be but
currently as far as I know it is check
it out in the category of underrated the
Magnificent Seven I had a total blast
with this movie and Wow
mostly positive reviews critics seemed
to feel the same way about almost every
Antoine Fuqua movie they all have very
similar ratings on Rotten Tomatoes it's
interesting and I feel like a lot of
people went to it expecting a more
serious film but I was just really
excited to see a great Western action
thriller shot on film and it looks
beautiful in the category of overlooked
hunt for the wilderness movie was so
funny
sam neill gave the best performance I've
seen from him since Jurassic Park this
is from the director of what we do in
the shadows and the upcoming Thor
Ragnarok this film was about a young boy
who gets lost in the woods because his
family life is awful and a guy who's
helping take care of him is Sam Neill
and they get lost in the woods together
and they go on an adventure I wish that
more people saw movies like this in
theaters because I got to see it in
theaters and I loved every minute of it
in the category of underrated
I'm just gonna say it x-men apocalypse I
don't get the hate I thought this movie
was awesome I really enjoyed this film
it has some flaws yes but I really
really don't get the low ratings from
critics people seem to think it's
alright but critics really trash this
one and I thought it was not really
deserved apocalypse didn't always work
for me as a villain and I can understand
people zero in on that but I thought the
action sequences the special effects the
performances especially from James
McAvoy and Michael Fassbender were all
top-notch I had a blast with x-men
apocalypse and I don't really get the
hate from the critics in the category of
overlooked I in the sky I saw this film
at home and it was like a crushing
weight on my soul this was a dark
depressing film that really took me on
an emotional journey into what it might
look like if you were in the middle of
warfare except you were sitting behind a
computer screen it's really intriguing
and I think it's a movie that asks a lot
of super important questions and if you
missed out on this one see it in the
category of underrated the accountant
critics were completely split on this
movie and I really enjoyed it
I thought Gavin O'Connor told this tale
in a very unique way it sometimes went
back to the past and then went back to
present and I really like the way that
he tied in the loose ends of his story
to make a cohesive movie
I thought Ben Affleck gave one of the
best performances of his career also the
action sequences were great I didn't
understand why critics were sour on this
one in the category of overlooked the
invitation I saw this film at home and
it started out and I was like okay all
right everyone's pretty good in this
movie good performances what's gonna
happen here okay we're getting into oh
okay now it's a movie Wow
aspects of the way this film concluded I
thought were a little bit cheesy but for
the most part this is a film that really
sneaks up on you and has a dark horrific
power to it in the category of
underrated Ouija - now critics like this
movie people on the other hand I don't
know what it is about Mike Flanagan he
makes really good horror films I like
pretty much every film he's made but
people have a hard time getting into
them I don't really know why I think
this was one of the best directed horror
films of the year right after the
conjuring - speaking of Mike Flanagan he
directed the movie hush and I found this
film very overlooked this is a Netflix
movie a horror film about a killer who
was stalking a deaf woman such a great
idea there were aspects of wait until
dark in there and some other films as
well but I found it white knuckled from
beginning to end in the category of
underrated regression this movie was
blasted by critics which I really didn't
get yes the ending is a bit
disappointing but I appreciated Ethan
Hawke's performance and the police
procedural aspect of this movie a lot
more than I think most people did I
found the film very eerie and very
off-putting even though in some ways the
story betrays itself it makes sense
because of that time period the film is
trying to recreate and the way people
felt at that time and in the way the rug
was kind of pulled out from underneath
people at that time this movie really
makes you feel the same way and I liked
it and last but not least overlooked you
probably knew this was coming - nice
guys this was my favorite movie of 2016
I really wish more people saw this film
critics loved it everyone I've ever
talked to either liked or loved this
movie but it didn't make any money
Shane black and everyone involved would
love to make more and I wish that that
could happen because this is my favor
movie of the year I think it has amazing
characters incredible dialogue and one
of the best scripts of the entire year
in fact it is my favorite script of 2016
guys those are my picks for some of the
more overlooked and underrated films of
2016 what are some of yours I would love
to know thank you so much for watching I
look forward to another year of movie
reviews with you guys you're the best
thank you once again and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you